neue niederlage für premier johnston der
britische parlamentspräsident burke
lässt eine zweite praxis abstimmung
nicht zu spitzenpolitiker im visier
morddrohungen und hass mails
überschatten den landtagswahlkampf in
thüringen diagnose depression 5,3
millionen menschen leiden in deutschland
daran eine neue kampagne will aufklären
und helfen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten die vom sport hat
norbert könig dabei schwimmen
erst sollte der vergangene samstag der
tag der entscheidung für johnsons black
city mit der eu seien dann heute doch
wieder nichts
diesmal hat parlamentspräsident john
bercow dem britischen premier einen
strich durch die rechnung gemacht bürger
entschied am späten nachmittag das
unterhaus darf nicht wie von der
regierung geplant ein zweites mal über
den neuen praxis ziel abstimmen
begründung es habe sicher nichts daran
geändert weder am inhalt noch an den
umständen im parlament da fragen wir
diana zimmermann in london wie geht es
denn jetzt weiter
jetzt geht es so weiter wie die
parlamentarier ist am samstag
geschlossen haben sie wollen ja dass das
gesamte gesetzespaket rundum wir
gesichert ist bevor sie der regierung
gestatten auszutreten
dieses gesetzespaket das rund 100 seiten
umfasst wird den abgeordneten heute
abend zum ersten mal vorgelegt ab morgen
soll dann darüber debattiert werden und
bis donnerstagabend so möchte es die
regierung sondern es durchs parlament
gepeitscht sein
das erste mal wird also morgen spannend
zu sehen wie die abgeordneten auf den
vorgeschlagenen zeitplan reagieren wenn
sie sagen das reicht uns nicht drei tage
um dieses komplexe gesetzeswerk das so
große bedeutung haben wird abzustimmen
und genau zu untersuchen
dann wissen wir schon morgen dass der
austritt am 31 oktober nicht mehr mit
dir nicht mehr möglich ist ja könnte das
ganze dann auch noch scheitern und
großbritannien ende des monats dann
tatsächlich die eben ohne deal verlassen
[Musik]
das ginge nur wenn die eu diese bitte um
verschiebungen die boris johnson zwar
widerwillig aber doch am samstagabend
nach brüssel geschickt hat ablehnen
würde allgemein wird erwartet dass sie
das nicht tun
und das würde bedeuten dass
großbritannien noch bis zum 31 januar
2020 zeit hat um sich zu überlegen ob es
den dreck cit will und was für einen
wechsel ist will der vielen dank dass
sie uns diesen bürger etwas klarer
gemacht haben diana danke
verteidigungsministerin kramp
karrenbauer fordert eine international
kontrollierte sicherheitszone im
syrischen grenzgebiet zur türkei einen
entsprechenden vorschlag habe sie mit
kanzlerin merkel abgestimmt und
westlichen verbündeten unterbreitet
dabei sollten die türkei und russland
einbezogen werden
ziel sei es die lage dort zu
deeskalieren und den kampf gegen die
terror miliz islamischer staat
fortzusetzen
der termin für die verabredete halbzeit
bilanz der großen koalition steht nun
fest anfang november wollen union und
spd vorstellen was sie erreicht haben
diesen termin nach der landtagswahl in
thüringen haben spitzen der schwarz
roten koalition gestern abend festgelegt
auf grundlage dieser bilanz wollen die
koalitionsparteien in den nächsten
wochen auch entscheiden ob sie ihr
regierungsbündnis fortsetzen
dass ein bischof wegen politischer
vorwürfe sein amt verliert ist äußerst
ungewöhnlich
doch die evangelische kirche in sachsen
hat heute den rücktritt ihres bisherigen
landesbischofs karsten renz lng
angenommen
ein grund der konservative geistliche
hatte vor vielen jahren in einer
ultra-rechten zeitschrift einen artikel
veröffentlicht der die demokratie in
frage stellt ob jetzt ruhe einkehrt ist
fraglich denn dem ex bischof sprang
zuletzt viele zur seite auch die
sächsische afd
michael beverungen demonstranten vor dem
dresdner landeskirchenamt konservative
christen demonstrieren für den verbleib
des landesbischofs im amt darunter auch
ein abgeordneter der afd
die hatte von einer hetzjagd auf torsten
renz ihnen gesprochen ich finde es ein
kesseltreiben man hätte seine
kritikpunkte fotos hat neue hoch schon
vor dem bau wochen gemacht man hat
gesucht man hat gefunden hat vor 30
jahren was geschrieben dass einige nicht
passt ich sage dass wir eine
konservative kultur trifft da muss nicht
alles drin stehen was ich mag
aber ich muss es aushalten
karsten renz in hatte sein amt zur
verfügung gestellt nachdem seine
mitgliedschaft in einer schlagenden
verbindung bekannt geworden war
dazu artikel aus rensings studienzeit
anfang der 90er jahre
darin hatte er demokratie und
menschenrechte in frage gestellt sätze
wie diesen geschrieben dass ein staat in
dem feigheit vor tapferkeit
selbstverwirklichung vor freiheit leben
vor ihre gilt dem untergang geweiht ist
dürfte kaum bezweifelt werden
rensing selbst nahm dazu bisher noch
kurz und schriftlich stellung der weg in
die kirche hat mich verändert position
die ich vor 30 jahren vertreten habe
teile ich heute nicht mehr
die kirchenleitung akzeptiert rensings
rücktritt und ist doch unsicher wo sie
in zukunft die grenzen ziehen soll
wie gehen wir eigentlich mit der frage
um was ist rechtsextrem und was ist eine
werte konservativer christ das heißt
also wir wollen festlegen oder uns
darüber beraten inwieweit die
bergpredigt zb als prüfstein genutzt
werden kann
ratlose gesichter an diesem abend die
evangelische kirche in sachsen muss sich
gegen rechtsextremismus abgrenzen
zugleich aber eine tiefe spaltung ihrer
gläubigen überwinden
morddrohungen gegen spitzenpolitiker
überschatten die endphase des wahlkampfs
in thüringen nach cdu-spitzenkandidat
mohring machte heute auch
grünen-fraktionschef adams bekannt droh
mails erhalten zu haben
als urheber vermuten die
sicherheitsbehörden in beiden fällen
rechtsextremisten die bundesregierung
dies mitteilen man beobachte die
morddrohungen mit großer sorge andreas
postel auf seinem twitter account
veröffentlicht mike mohring das jüngste
drohschreiben an ihn in der e-mail
fordern die absender der thüringer cdu
spitzenkandidat solle seinen wahlkampf
einstellen
ansonsten drohten ihm konsequenzen
erklärt er in einem online video wenn
ich das nicht tue
da wollten sie mich abstechen sowie die
oberbürgermeisterin von köln henriette
reker oder gar eine autobombe zünden
ich habe mich entschlossen die
öffentlichkeit zu treten und mit zeichen
zu setzen dem entgegenzutreten dass
einschüchterung nicht zum erfolg führt
lka ermittelt auch wegen einer weiteren
morddrohung die mohring bereits ende
september erhalten hatte
die drohung gegen ihn kein einzelfall
auch der spitzenkandidat der thüringer
grünen dirk adams macht nun ebenfalls
eine morddrohung gegen sich öffentlich
darin wird ein messer oder autobomben
attentaten gedroht adams habe auch das
lka eingeschaltet nehme das krude
drohschreiben ansonsten nicht besonders
ernst
thüring safety spitzenkandidat türen
höcke dagegen steht seit jahren wegen
einer besonderen bedrohungslage unter
polizeischutz
so kurz vor der landtagswahl zeigt sich
thüringens innenminister besorgt die
staatsanwaltschaft führte ermittlungen
wir prüfen das natürlich sehr
wir gehen mit nachdruck soll ich mal
diesen drogen mal versuchen
herauszufinden wer sie woher sie kommen
es gibt technische möglichkeiten auch
thüringens ministerpräsident ramelow sah
sich in der vergangenheit mehrfach
morddrohungen ausgesetzt
in diesem zusammenhang gab es am freitag
mehrere hausdurchsuchungen in thüringen
dabei stellten lka beamte bei einem
polizeibekannten rechtsextremisten in
pößneck illegale waffen sicher
der kampf für die arbeitnehmerrechte
seit mittlerweile 70 jahren das zentrale
anliegen des dgb der deutsche
gewerkschaftsbund feiert sein
gründungsjubiläum
die urkunde unterschrieben im oktober
seitdem fordert der dgb mehr
mitbestimmung mit dem slogan samstags
gehört vati mir wurde in den 60ern etwa
die 40 stunden woche durchgesetzt heute
braucht es neue antworten in eine neuen
arbeitswelt lassen sagt berichtet 70
jahre dgb sieben jahrzehnte in denen die
gewerkschaften und ihr dachverband zu
einer festen stütze der sozialen
marktwirtschaft geworden sind lobt die
kanzlerin in ihrer laudatio die
sozialpartnerschaft in deutschland
zwingt geradezu den deutschen
gewerkschaftsbund und die
einzelgewerkschaften immer wieder auch
verantwortung zu übernehmen und mit
konstruktiven lösungsvorschläge
aufzutreten
ob betriebliche mitbestimmung
kündigungsschutz oder die
fünf-tage-woche die gewerkschaften haben
viel erreicht in den letzten 70 jahren
doch die arbeitswelt ist im umbruch
neben traditionellen großbetrieben mit 4
mitbestimmung gibt es immer mehr
befristete stellen outsourcing und
start-ups ohne betriebsrat die sichere
welt sozusagen der großbetriebe der
exportorientierten industrie im metall-
und im chemiebereich so das funktioniert
es gut und in den anderen bereichen
funktioniert eben kaum so und da ist die
herausforderung für die gewerkschaften
auch diesen bereich der der prekären
dienstleistungen den sich stärker zu
erschließen
digitalisierung und globalisierung
wälzen die arbeitswelt um noch haben die
gewerkschaften keine klaren antworten
geben sich aber dennoch optimistisch das
stellt gewerkschaften immer wieder vor
neue herausforderungen
gerade in zeiten eines rasanten
strukturwandels allen feiern zum trotz
der umbruch in der arbeitswelt wird auch
von den gewerkschaften
ganz neue strategien verlangen bei den
anhaltenden unruhen in chile sind
mindestens zehn menschen ums leben
gekommen
die toten wurden nach bränden in
verschiedenen gebäuden der haupt in der
hauptstadt santiago gefunden
die gewaltsamen proteste waren nach
einer fahrpreiserhöhung der dortigen u
bahn ausgebrochen und hatten sich rasch
aufs ganze land ausgeweitet präsident
pinera sprach im fernsehen von krieg und
nannte die demonstranten einen mächtigen
und unerbittlichen feind die usa haben
ein suchtproblem seit ende der 90er
jahre sind hunderttausende gestorben
durch opioid haltige schmerzmittel ab
heute sollte vor gericht die mitschuld
mehrere pharmakonzerne geklärt werden
doch anstelle eines riesigen prozesses
gab es einen vergleich in den
vergangenen zwei jahrzehnten haben ob
juli teilige schmerzmitteln millionen
amerikaner in die sucht getrieben
allein 2017 starben mehr als 47.000 an
einer überdosis 130 tote pro tag wegen
der übermäßigen verschreibung von
schmerzmitteln aus den usa ines trams
herren und seine mutter sind glücklich
nach jahren der abhängigkeit ist er
heute drogenfrei schmerztabletten haben
ihn süchtig gemacht opioide die er nach
einer operation bekam dann irgendwann
erkannte er ich kann nicht mehr ohne
es war großartig ich fühlte mich einfach
wie eine komplett andere person
wann immer mehr die schmerzmittel
ausgingen habe ich meine wunden hat
wieder aufgerissen damit ich vom
krankenhaus eine neue verschreibung
bekam jackson ohio
im schnitt erhält jeder bürger hier über
100 opioid haltige tabletten im jahr von
ärzten zu freizügig verschrieben die
suchtgefahr von den pharmafirmen lange
verschleiert fast alle fälle die richter
music am örtlichen gericht bearbeitet
haben mit drogen zu tun
bist du fragt er jeden beschuldigten
auch als vater ist eher betroffen sein
sohn verstarb an einer überdosis
er weiß die sucht zerreißt die kommunen
dorfstraße tod bringt die sucht
zerstörung und armut die
vernachlässigung von kindern nimmt
drastisch zu
die kosten für unsere kleine gemeinde
sind riesig es überfordert und es
zerstört uns richtig findet sheriff ray
das über 2000 landkreise und städte die
pharmafirmen verklagt haben zwei
landkreise haben nun einen vergleich
erzielt sie bekommen 260 millionen
dollar zugesprochen
darauf hofft er dann auch für seinen
landkreis denn wir haben den höhepunkt
der epidemie noch nicht einmal erreicht
jetzt sind wir konfrontiert mit den
kindern die drogenabhängig geboren
werden uns fehlt an allem
ahrens familie setzt darauf dass diese
erste einigung mit den pharmafirmen
wegweisend sein wird für die weiteren
klagen auch der ihres landkreises auch
die depression ist eine
lebensgefährliche krankheit wie
schmerzen hier sind eher seelischer
natur können aber auch sehr körperlich
werden tiefe traurigkeit lähmende angst
in deutschland leiden 5,3 millionen
menschen unter solchen symptomen
betroffen sind 11,3 prozent der frauen
doppelt so viele wie männer
depressionen können bis zum suizid
führen wie im fall von nationaltorwart
robert enke
die nach ihm benannte stiftung kämpft
gegen die schwere krankheit über ihre
neue aufklärungskampagne britta
spiekermann
sie sucht die öffentlichkeit die witze
von robert enke spricht über die
depressionen ihres mannes über ihre
damalige persönliche situation gefragt
wie fühlt man sich was wie kann sich ein
depressiver fühlen und er hat mir das
eben mit diesem tunnel beschrieben aber
ich konnte nicht wirklich eintauchen
jedes jahr nehmen sich 10.000 menschen
aufgrund von depressionen das leben
jetzt startet eine aufklärungskampagne
es ist nach meiner wahrnehmung ein
offeneres klima in der gesellschaft
dafür da über eine psychische erkrankung
über eine depression zu sprechen
aber es ist auch noch nicht so das ist
völlig tabu frei wäre
mit virtual reality brillen sollen
gesunde menschen die krankheit besser
verstehen und nachvollziehen können und
lange halte das nicht mehr aus
ich bin so traurig dass ich es kaum doch
trage keine schuld gar nichts mehr
mir ist nur leere der torwart von
hannover 96 hatte sich vor zehn jahren
das leben genommen
von seinen schweren depressionen wusste
kaum jemand ab zehntausende nahmen
damals abschied
seine witwe will aus der tragödie etwas
gutes machen
ich möchte den menschen eben vermitteln
dass es eine krankheit ist dass es
halber ist dass es nichts mit schwäche
zu tun hat lieber alleine reiche nicht
um zu helfen sagt sie
es brauche mehr professionelle hilfe und
davon gebe es nicht genug
wir sind beim sport morgen das dritte
gruppenspiel in der champions league für
die bayern aber die stimmung ist
gedrückt arbeit ja der ausfall von
niklas süle und die enttäuschung in
augsburg die haben bei den fc bayern ein
bisschen spuren hinterlassen aber bayern
trainer niko kovac ist trotz dieser
jüngsten rückschläge optimistisch dass
die erfolgsserie in der königsklasse bei
olympiakos piräus eine fortsetzung
findet nicht so verschlafen wie in
augsburg wollen die bayern zu werk gehen
und der trainer nennt noch eine andere
baustelle im vergleich zum letzten jahr
haben wir ich glaube 15 tore mehr
geschossen das heißt nach vorne hin sind
wir sehr viel effektiver geworden haben
drei gegentreffer mehr
das heißt da müssen wir dran arbeiten
und das dürfte nach dem ausfall von
niklas süle noch schwieriger werden
der inzwischen operierte abwehrchef
fällt monatelang aus schlägt nun doch
die stunde von jerome boateng seine
dienste schienen zum saisonwechsel gar
nicht mehr erwünscht für den am samstag
noch betont schweigsamen uli hoeneß ist
es wichtiger dass rafi martinez vor der
abwehr auf räumt der präsident als
ratgeber in aufstellungsfragen das war
und allein die entscheidung meines
trainers team seines trainerteams und
meiner person
das musste ja mal gesagt werden siege
serie beendet 17 spiele nacheinander
hatte jürgen klopp mit dem fc liverpool
saisonübergreifend gewannen in der
premier league jetzt gab es ein 1 1 bei
manchester united mit diskussionsbedarf
liverpools motto gestern lautete wenn du
nicht gewinnen kannst dann verliere
wenigstens nicht aus sicht von jürgen
klopp ein spiel mit strittigen
entscheidungen beispiel 36 minuten die
führung für manunited fort doch den
treffer ging ein vermeintliches foul
voraus originals lindelof der video
assistent entschied das tor zählt
für mich war das so klar ein foul und
somit kein tor
ich war so überrascht dass ich nicht
einmal wütend sein konnte wirklich ein
ganz großes missverständnis wenig später
erneut aufregung bei jürgen klopp erneut
kam es zum videobeweis die hand im spiel
bei money der ausgleich kurz vor der
pause zählte nicht nach dem
seitenwechsel liverpool stärker clubs
joker de la lanne kurz vor dem ende mit
dem ausgleich ein punkt gerettet
liverpool bleibt tabellenführer in der
premier league also nicht wirklich ein
rückschlag zum wetter endlich bleibt es
eher trocken dazu kommt auch die sonne
raus jedenfalls da wo sie den nebel
durch trägt zu den einzelheiten gleich
gunter czisch das war es von uns claus
kleber erwartet sie um drei viertel 10
zum heute-journal und wir sind morgen
abend wieder zur stelle punkt 7 danke
für ihre aufmerksamkeit und noch einen
schönen abend tschüss
[Musik]
kohl nahm liebe zuschauer in dieser
woche gibt es viel sonnenschein aber
eben auch nebel
derzeit steigt ja der luftdruck über
mitteleuropa und das bedeutet die
regengebiete ziehen sich langsam zurück
dieses hier im südwesten
das haben wir noch heute nacht aber
morgen früh ist es schon vorbei und den
nächsten tagen haben wir dann das ruhige
wetter meist mit sonne und nebel und
kein regen mehr
heute nacht haben aber noch ein bisschen
regen so vom schwarzwald bis zum einen
in der zweiten nachthälfte wird danach
lassen dann bilden sich nebelfelder hier
in den flussniederungen zum teil und im
nordwesten wird es doch wahrscheinlich
an der nordsee bewölkt bleiben morgen
haben wir auch dort im nordwesten die
dichtere bewölkung ab und zu geht es mal
einen kleinen regenschauer das wird
nicht viel sein
dazu wird dieser frische west oder
südwestwind nach osten hin sieht
freundlicher aus da scheint meist die
sonne das wird genauso in der mitte und
im süden sein
doch dann haben wir eben den nebel hier
an der donau am bodensee am oberrhein
aber auch am main und teilweise hält er
sich bis zum nachmittag dazu weht auch
nur ein ganz schwacher nordostwind am
wärmsten wird es wieder im osten und
süden meist sind das so zwischen 17 und
19 grad oder in der lausitz auch mal 20
sonst sind es 14 bis 16 grad es bleibt
mild in den nächsten tagen sieht auch
ziemlich trocken aus meist scheint die
sonne aber zum teil hält sich auch nebel
und hochnebel ich wünschen noch einen
schönen abend und machen sie es gut